es gibt leider tatsächlich noch kein
aufatmen hier in oppenau
die polizei sucht weiterhin nach ehefrau
hier in den wäldern rund um open wir
konnten gestern beobachten wie immer
wieder das sek und spezialkräfte hiervon
sammelplatz der polizei an dass oppenau
ausgerückt sind wir können auch
beobachten wie gestern eine verdächtige
person im ort festgenommen oder in
gewahrsam genommen wurde
das hat sich aber nachher als einst eine
fehlt spur herausgestellt aber es kommen
immer wieder hinweise von anwohnern auch
verdächtige personen den geht man hier
natürlich nach in den wäldern hier und
auch den feldwegen ist die polizei sehr
präsent man versucht das gebiet das ja
ein riesiges ist so gut es geht zu
überwachen und ihr habt gestern ja ein
interview gemacht euch getroffen mit
einem förster denn der ball spielt eine
ganz große rolle
der regen hat die bodenbeschaffenheit
etwas versteht das heißt in form das
schlecht begehbar ist und auch die
sichtweise in die bestände rheine oder
im bestand selbst dann ganz erhebliche
einschränkungen mit sich bringen ich
möchte einfach hier verdeutlichen wie
schwierig sich sowohl maßnahme gestaltet
die derzeit von den polizisten von dem
polizeiaufgebot hier so viel abverlangt
gibt natürlich ganz charakters
versteckmöglichkeiten
es ist ganz besonders schwer die
polizisten sind ausgerüstet mit ihrem
persönlichen gut dass sie mittragen
müsse was auch den dienst abverlangt und
finde dann alle möglichkeiten an
hindernisse dann in unserem großteils
von den meldungen vor
so haben diese parameter aus diesem
unterstand herauszukommen bei dem
morgendlichen regel der hat jetzt schon
seine spuren hinterlassen als
schulleitung die frage ist sicher besser
eingedeckt als hätte ich heute morgen
aber es fällt ihm sicher auch schwer mit
dem geordneten maße umzugehen
die polizei geht es natürlich auch nicht
anders ja es ist tatsächlich ist so das
ist mal auf den punkt bringen möchte es
wird schwierig sein frauchen diesen
dicht bewaldeten gebiet mit ganz ganz
wenig freiflächen nur 20 prozent aus
unserer gemeinde frau stand wirklich zu
finden
auf den punkt gebracht es wäre fast wie
eine nadel im heuhaufen ja sascha wir
haben es gerade gehört es wird sehr sehr
schwierig herauszufinden meinte der
förster dort in diesem dichten wald wie
sieht denn die strategie der polizei für
die nächsten tage aus wird man dort
suchen bis man ihn dann gefasst hat oder
ja ändert man die strategie wie hubert
fischer hat es ja schon gesagt es ist
die suche der nadel im heuhaufen und das
ist wirklich ein riesiges waldgebiet das
sind ungefähr acht quadratkilometer von
denen 80 prozent bewaldet sind teilweise
so dicht dass man vom hubschrauber aus
nur die baumkronen sehen kann man kann
überhaupt nicht bis zum boden runter
sehen da haben auch die wärmebildkameras
einen hubschrauber der polizei ihre
probleme dort irgendwas zu erfassen
dazu kommt natürlich dass es bis heute
nacht stark geregnet hat und die es ist
nicht nur schwieriges gelände sondern es
ist mittlerweile auch gefährlich sich
dort zu bewegen weil es eben dort auch
viele felswände hat die man nicht so
einfach besteigen kann ich glaube man
wird sich auf intensive
fahndungsmaßnahmen im ort aber auch um
die wälder herum beschränken immer
wieder mit dem hubschrauber von oben
schauen
möglicherweise macht die frauscher
irgendwann einen fehler vielleicht auch
durch die nässe und die kälte zermürbt
du wirst weiter berichten sascha baumann
ganz herzlichen dank